now a lot of people don't know this but
Eddie is in fact a highly trained master
magician now you remember the magic
circle like beat despair and loss when I
was a child
please tell me you're about to your
brows you can do amazing magic because
we have here just a totally ordinary
coloring Oh totally ordinary oh but
Eddie can do magic with it isn't that
right Eddie I mean are you sitting
comfortably children no
[Applause]
okay daddy's got it so excited I love
Paul Daniels he probably went to
Whoville ten years late Paul Daniels was
an amazing magician that used to be on
telly every Saturday night I was
obsessed with him and I this is my
moment to be on television doing magic
when are you ready I'm maybe already
knows that this is a coloring book there
is nothing weird or bizarre about it
other than it says the word magic on the
front of it there is actually nothing in
the coloring book I'm showing you you
see there's nothing in it but Brian yes
will you blow on the coloring book
[Laughter]
let's let's see what that's Donna shall
we
[Applause]
okay so the next stage is so we've
gotten how we have pictures been we have
pictures pictures will you blow on it
we awful small no it wasn't her wizard
[Applause]
[Laughter]
maybe for full-on Marvel like the well
will you give us a spell Ben as a
pitcher yeah
[Applause]
thank you for teasing is my place this
Burnham burn
[Applause]
[Music]